You need to be OK with being
bad to start because sucking
is the first step to being
sort of good at something.
I'm gonna teach
you everything I've
learned as cofounder of
Reddit and an investor
in multiple billion
dollar companies
so that you can go from your
own idea to actually executing
your dreams. There
is no shortage of things
that need to be improved.
It's about realizing
what you're gonna work on
and then how to
actually get started.
Most good ideas have
lots of competitors.
You should listen
to your customers.
to their customers
but pay no attention
to what they're doing.
The best way to break in is
building the most basic version
of your product, and
even if it's janky,
it's proof of execution.
If you're meeting with
an investor, what
you've got to get across
in the first few minutes
is that there's a clear problem,
a clear need, and a huge market
opportunity if we get it right.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]